you interested in free room and border
union salary and little no
responsibility i suppose i'd give it a
shot
the best opportunity to stop free navy
is here here and here and if you don't
we have a plan b
all parts stand by for launch everyone
pucker up it's about to get rough
there's a reactor
we need air support negative those rail
guns will be all over us the second we
stick our nose out
i'd rather get shot in the front in the
back
me too
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'll be doing
the final preview video for the final
episode of the expanse it's a
bittersweet occasion but we might as
well make the most of it and the teasers
they put out are a little more
substantial than the ones we've had for
previous episodes in season six they're
actually kind of crazy looking and we'll
also talk about what i think is the last
installment in the x-ray series that
came out with episode 5 and was titled
remember the cant it's a trip to the
past with a much younger looking holden
before he signed on to the canterbury
i'll be getting into all of that after
this quick spoiler warning if any of
what i just mentioned sounded like
spoilers then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it
the x-ray mini episode opens with a
voiceover with holden saying that the
doctrine of one ship encompasses the
physical and the abstract the known and
the imagined space and time the future
and the past in the present day on the
docks of series we see him standing
there looking at what turns out to be
the old graffiti with his face saying
remember the cant monica comes up and
asks what he thinks that guy would have
to say about everything that's going on
and holden replies that he'd probably
tell them to keep their heads down and
stay out of trouble she gives him a hug
before she leaves and then we flash back
to 10 years earlier we catch up with
captain mcdowell who we met in the very
first episode of the first season he's
at a bar on series and he has some of
his porcelain cat figurines along for
the ride and we see him ask for a drink
as he's standing next to the season one
character who was named the gaunt belter
in the credits he gets abrasive with him
because he's an earther and mcdowell
says sarcastically that hey you know
you're welcome for all that clean water
we're bringing to the station and flips
him off then another familiar character
this time from season two makes a return
and smashes one of his figurines when he
comes up to the bar at one of the tables
a clean shaven younger looking holden is
drinking with a bunch of belters he's
telling a funny story where he was nude
he was trying to get his pants back in a
situation where he couldn't communicate
so he tried to make a gesture to explain
what he wanted but he was inadvertently
propositioning the guy so everyone
laughs at his expense mcdowell comes up
and asks him if he's an earther in the
process he insults everyone at the table
because he says hey you know you're
really good with these people referring
to the belters he tells him he has a
line on a job and holden isn't
interested as he's about to walk away he
decides to make him a more attractive
sounding offer saying you interested in
free room and board a union salary and
little to no responsibility this turns
out to be exactly what holden's looking
for and he decides to hire on to the
cant so two pretty great character
returns these characters both had small
but memorable roles the gaunt belter was
the face of series in episode 1 in the
voice of the belter people and that was
truly our first introduction to them in
their situation he did show up in the
first episode of season six and i'm glad
they found another way to work him in
before it was all said and done the
second character was listed in the
credits as surly belter crewman when he
made his appearance in season 2 episode
8. this is also the episode where we're
introduced to prax and this belter
casually spaced all of the passengers
that were from the inner planets on a
refugee ship coming from ganymede and
that included his friend doris who we
saw taking care of him when we first
meet him so yeah two small but really
important roles as far as fleshing out
the world and it's great that they were
able to bring them back young holden was
a nice surprise and i thought they did a
great job of showing where he came from
who he was at the beginning of this what
a journey he's had from literally just
looking around trying to do the least
amount possible and get through life
without any real responsibility this
chance occurrence set him on a path to
meet all of the future crew members of
his family on the rossi which they'll
find themselves in the middle of
something huge when the cant gets
destroyed and it's a perfect reminder of
just how epic the journey they've been
on that they've taken together is going
into the series finale
episode 6 is titled babylon's ashes
after the book it was primarily based on
which has been the standard practice for
each of the season finales i haven't
seen an official description yet but did
see that the authors daniel abraham and
ty frank and show runner naren shankar
got the writing credit together with
brock eisner directing he's directed
several episodes throughout the series
including the finales for season four
and season five plus episode one of
season six they put out two short
teasers on social media yesterday which
are a little longer and also a little
spoilery they actually give away a
pretty big event from the season finale
the first teaser opens with admiral
siddiqui showing avasarala and her
advisors a plan to try to stop the free
navy before they make it to the ring
gate this is what they were discussing
in the last episode and there the
admiral admitted that there was a chance
it wouldn't work so avasarala asks what
happens if they aren't able to stop them
and holden says they have a plan b and
he says it with a fairly serious look on
his face from there it cuts to a shot of
the rossi approaching the ring and
they're with a larger ship that looks
like a hauler rather than a military
vessel holden says standby for launch
and we see bobby having a bumpy ride in
her armor and she says everyone pucker
up it's about to get rough you can also
see that amos is right there with her in
a suit as well then you see what looks
like shipping containers being ejected
from the back of the hauler which is
something we did see in the preseason
teasers here though you do get a better
look as they are moving through the gate
and can see that it's a combination of
makeshift container vessels with some
skiffs and shuttles mixed in there after
that you see bobby and amos land on the
surface of the ring station in their
suits you hear bobby say that the
reactor's over there as she's pointing
and there's a shot of what looks like
the railgun firing that makes it look
like things are pretty hairy also the
railgun looks gigantic when you see it
up close then it looks like they take
cover somewhere and call for air support
as you see the rossi using medina
station to shield themselves from
getting shot holden says they can't move
to assist them and then you hear amos
tell bobby i'd rather get shot in the
front rather than the back and she
agrees that teaser ends there and it
looks like the second one picks up right
after that in that one bobby's
approaching the base of the railgun
firing her built-in multi-barrel rotary
gun which looks pretty cool you do see
some damage on her face shield it looks
like she's been hit and in the hud
there's an icon that reads rpg and
another one that says target on the base
of the gun in front of her you see her
sort of flipping head over heels and
touching down on the deck and when you
see amos he looks pretty worried and
then the teaser ends with her fighting
her way back up to her feet and looking
at the target it all looks action-packed
with a lot of impressive looking visual
effects and they did a good job of
pairing amos and bobby in scenes
together leading up to this which does
add an extra dimension in the process of
delivering some hype and that's all
there really is to say we're almost at
the end of the road i've got a couple
more live streams coming up and some
other videos besides the one i'll be
doing for the finale so we'll try to
keep the conversation going even though
the show is coming to an end let me know
in the comments what you think about
these teasers and baby holden and what
you're hoping to see in the finale
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon